bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dont quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à favoriser
l'accès au crédit des petites et
moyennes entreprises
cette proposition de loi a été adopté
hier par les sénateurs
il faut dire qu'avec la crise financière
les pme ont de plus en plus de mal à
accéder au crédit pour leur faciliter
l'emprunt bancaire le gouvernement a
nommé un médiateur du crédit rené ricol
en débloquant 913 millions d'euros il a
permis à près de 5000 entreprises d'être
confortées dans leurs activités
mais pour les parlementaires il s'agit
d'aller plus loin avec cette proposition
de loi
en essayant de responsabiliser tous les
acteurs du crédit mais également en
imposant aux banques de motiver leur
refus de crédit et en sanctionnant les
établissements bancaires qui ne
respecteraient pas les conditions
légales d'octroi de crédit voilà pour
les enjeux de la séance de cet après
midi bonne séance à tous la discussion
générale donc est close et nous passons
à la discussion du texte élaboré par la
commission monsieur passionnant sur
l'article 1er
trop mais est-ce que vous pouvez très
bien
il n'a malheureusement pas été retenu je
souhaitais intervenir dans le cadre de
la discussion générale
malheureusement il semblerait qu'il ya
eu un loupé au niveau de mon inscription
aussi pour vous sensibiliser sur
l'urgence qu'il y avait à disposition
des pme ultramarines des produits
adaptés qui répondent réellement à leurs
attentes et surtout à notre volonté
commune de voir ces autres maires
rentrer dans une logique de
développement endogène je me vois
contraint d'utiliser le la possibilité
de parole sur articles et notamment sur
cet article
1 dans le type d'ailleurs reflète bien
la situation des pme ultramarines cet
article un porte sur les réductions aux
interruptions de crédit aux pme ce qui
est quasiment le cas pour nos pme
ultramarines qui sont en rupture de
crédit je reviens d'une mission dans les
quatre dom et le constat est une amine
unanime nos pme d'outre-mer sont en
rupture de crédit certes il existe un
système bancaire dans les dom avec
principalement des banques commerciales
qui sont des filiales ou antenne de
banque nationale mais elle se
caractérise par une trop forte
sélectivité en matière de crédit
orienté principalement sur le commerce
les services les crédits à la
consommation et les crédits immobiliers
en revanche son implication dans les
actions volontaristes en matière de
développement économique est très limité
alors pas de d'accès au crédit pour les
secteurs productifs notamment la pêche
de l'agriculture
tous les dispositifs de soutien aux
secteurs prioritaires ne sont pas
utilisés c'est le cas des taux bonifiés
à l'agriculture à la pêche due forme
développement des petites et moyennes
industries des prêts idéal un vert à
l'investissement des prêts participent
participatif au développement la sofaris
ne peut intervenir que dans le secteur
du commerce et des services
et malheureusement n'est pas orienté
vers le secteur industriel et dans la
création d'entreprise résultat les
économies d outre-mer sont de plus en
plus car series et même quand elle
présente de réels atouts dans le secteur
productif
aussi si l'on veut que le développement
endogène des outre-mer préconisées par
le gouvernement notamment par le chef de
l'état à plusieurs reprises ne devienne
pas qu'un simple effet d'annonce il
convient d'apporter un certain nombre
d'améliorations dispositif actuellement
en place il existe certaines pistes de
réflexion tels l'adaptation aux
outremers des produits oseo bdpme la
majeure partie de ces produits ne sont
pas pour l'instant distribué dans les
outre-mer ou bien quand ils le sont ils
ne sont pas adaptés
il est évident que ces produits sont
loin de convenir à des entreprises
intervenant dans les territoires qui ne
sont même pas pour certains en phase de
décollage
il ya des adaptations qui doivent
s'imposer et nous pensons que oseo sous
le couvert de l'afd peut très bien
assuré cette possibilité il faut
également redéployer l'activité de la
sofaris pour que les garanties sofaris
soient toutes présentes dans les outre
mer il s'agit de pistes de réflexion qui
peuvent rapidement être transformé en
mesure hier comme premier gage d'une
véritable politique de développement
endogène
en attendant la mise en place d'un
dispositif complet de financement en
échange vous en êtes en charge du
développement économique
les toits l'état pardon doit les prendre
en considération autrement tout ce qui
aura été annoncé jusqu'à maintenant le
restera quand dans le domaine de
l'intention
merci chaque collègue nous en arrivons
donc à l'article 1er donc le premier
amendement 11 rectifier il est présenté
par monsieur arthuis si monsieur le
président c'est un amendement qui donne
un peu plus de champ situation qui
justifie et que une entreprise demande
des explications sur le retrait des
crédits c'est pour ça que l'on substitue
à la mention article l561 19 qui est
très restrictive une réflexion plus
large dans le respect des dispositions
légales et réglementaires applicables
le reste du texte l'avis de la
commission
je mène
de solliciter l'avis du gouvernement sur
cet amendement
en le regardant je me pose quelques
questions supplémentaires et je ne sais
pas je ne crois pas qu'il soit très
usuels que dans un texte de loi et on
subordonne une disposition au respect
des dispositions légales et
réglementaires applicables
alors donc dans le respect des
dispositions légales applicables
absolument voilà deux telle sorte
effectivement qu'il ne résulte pas de
cet amendement une interprétation
susceptible de conduire les banques à
s'exonérer facilement mais bon dès lors
que l'on se borne à se référer aux
obligations légales ça ne devrait pas
être le cas
ceci étant dit la commission s'en
remettre à l'avis du gouvernement
général quel l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur ministre le gouvernement est
favorable à cet amendement avec la
précision forte utile qu'un cas
introduites jean arthuis en supprimant
la référence réglementaire la rédaction
actuelle en effet de l'article 1er de
cette proposition de loi neuville qui ne
vise qu'un seul cap dispense légal de
motivation de l'interruption de la
réduction du concours accordés une
entreprise celle précisément de
l'article l561 19 et donc en supprimant
cette référence
eh bien on va permettre que d'autres cas
de dispenses soit susceptible d'être
introduit à l'avenir la formulation que
vous proposez permettra effectivement
maintenir la portée de la rédaction du 2
de l'article 1er est de laisser la
possibilité d'introduire à l'avenir
d'autres cas de dispense eh bien le
gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement
ainsi est rectifiée par le
sous-amendement si j'ose dire en séance
de monsieur jean arthuis merci monsieur
le ministre pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement 11
rectifié bis d'albi
un levé la main merci
ceux qui sont contre veuille bien levé
la main l'amendement est adopté un
amendement numéro 6 il est présenté par
monsieur bérard messieurs président du
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
indiquées dans la discussion générale
que les intentions de l'auteur de
révision de loi était peut-être louable
mais ce qui ressort de l'examen du texte
dont nous débattons sait que sa portée
normative est très réduite et l'article
premier de ce texte suffit en lui-même
pour confirmer cette impression de fait
dans un premier temps on fixe à 60 jours
le délai dans lequel un établissement de
crédit ne pourra procéder à la
suspension d'un crédit d'exploitation
accordait une entreprise et dans un
second temps on demande que le refus de
l'établissement de crédit soit à la
demande du prêteur expressément motivé
mais en définitive cela ne change rien à
la situation de l'entreprise concernée
c'est pourquoi notre amendement vise à
donner une force un peu plus nette à la
mesure préconisée par l'article 1er nous
proposons que le refus d'accorder un
prêt bancaire à une pme ou une tpe
emporte déclenchement
terme bis du drot compte un droit d'eau
je rappelle qu'il est de par la loi
ouvert tant aux particuliers qu'aux
personnes morales c'est à dire aux
entreprises à porter même s'il vous
plaît monsieur devra partager résident
donc je comprends que dans l'esprit de
l'auteur
la décision d'une banque de réduire
d'interrompre son crédit conduirait à la
mise en oeuvre de la procédure du régime
du droit au quand et du régime des fonds
reçus du public et de la garantie des
déposants et j'ai un peu de peine à
comprendre l'enchaînement des opérations
et l'anah la faisabilité de ceux de ce
dispositif le caractère opératoire du
dispositif
je n'ai pas creusé la question de
manière déterminante mais peut-être que
je suis beau redonner la vie de la
commission à ce que le ministre aura à
nous dire
je remercie monsieur le rapporteur le
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président le gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement
et je voudrais et saluer la prescience
de du rapporteur général kiki
ne vois pas comment il pourrait
fonctionner c'est vrai que cet
amendement n'est pas adapté à ce l'objet
qui est poursuivie de soutenir les
entreprises qui peuvent avoir une
suppression une réduction des concours
accordés
vous proposez de procédure l'exercice du
droit aux comptes et le l'appel au fonds
de garantie des dépôts by les deux
procédures ne se trouve pas à
s'appliquer dans le cas dans ce cas
spécifique qu'est ce que c'est que
l'exercice du droit aux comptes
eh bien c'est la possibilité de
bénéficier d'un compte et donc
l'exercice du droit aux comptes est ici
sans objet dans la mesure où
l'interruption ou la réduction d'un
concours bancaire ne vaut pas clôture du
compte ce n'est pas parce qu'un
établissement de crédit interrompt le
concours qu'il accorde à une entreprise
qu'il va résilier le compte qu'elle
détient chez lui ok ça n'a pas de lien
et deuxième procédure que vous
mentionnez celle relative au fonds de
garantie des dépôts belle dans ce cas
précis je ne trouve pas non plus à
s'appliquer car ce dispositif prévoit
que le fonds indemnise les déposants en
cas d'indisponibilité de leurs dépôts or
l'interruption d'un concours ne vaut pas
un disponibilité des dépôts effectués
par l'entreprise
rien ne justifie donc l'intervention en
l'espèce du fonds de garantie des dépôts
cet amendement et je le regrette et donc
inapplicable en l'état
et en outre correspond pas à la réalité
des pratiques des établissements de
crédit devereaux merci monsieur le
ministre
s'il ya des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas chez consul qui sont
ceux qui sont favorables mandement
présentée par monsieur verra veulent
bien levé la mare avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adopté alors je
consulte le sénat sur l'article 1er ceux
qui sont favorables sont priées de lever
la main avis contraire l'article 1er est
adopté
même vote pour l'article de l article 3
je remercie nous passons à l'article 3
bis un amendement présenté par monsieur
vera et d'amendements numéro 3 s'il vous
plaît oui merci monsieur président cet
amendement revient sur une question
essentielle celle de la collecte de
l'épargné populaire et celle de son
utilisation question d'autant plus
d'actualité que ces mises en place
depuis janvier dernier la distribution
des produits de l'épargné réglementée
par l'ensemble des réseaux bancaires
nous sommes partisans parce qu'il faut
que nous trouvions des voies et moyens
de la relance de l'activité économique
décentralisation renforcée des sommes
collectées au livret au titre du livret
a et du livret de développement durable
et nous sommes partisans d'une forme
d'égalité de traitement entre les
collecteurs encadrant plus strictement
la faculté laissée aux nouveaux
collecteurs de ne pas mettre en oeuvre
la centralisation les ressources
collectées nous avons besoin d'argent
disponible pour l'emploi pour
l'investissement dans le secteur du
logement pour soutenir le tissu
importante pme et tpe qui travaillent
dans ce secteur comme nous avons besoin
d'offrir aux petites entreprises de
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité des
moyens financiers nouveaux assise
notamment sur la collecte du livret de
développement durable
quelques lags avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
celui ci reconnaît j'ai le sentiment que
la préoccupation de notre collègue
s'adressait davantage au texte initial
de la proposition de loin et que le
dispositif élaboré par la commission et
qui fait précisément l'objet du présent
article 3 bis est de nature à satisfaire
les préoccupations exprimées par
monsieur verra puisque l'on a bien prévu
la centralisation des fonds dont il
s'agirait caisse des dépôts la non
rémunération de cette centralisation
forcer une période de référence est de
mise en oeuvre de la sanction fixez un
trimestre donc ceci me paraît
opérationnel et je le répète répondre
aux préoccupations que vous avez exprimé
mon chapeau alex qui devrait normalement
vous permettre de retirer l'amendement
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
s'il vous plaît monsieur le ministre
excusez moi monsieur le président le
gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement parce que je voudrais en
quelques mots indiqué que comprendrait
beaucoup de risques si nous adoptions
votre amendement car recentraliser à la
caisse des dépôts les les sommes qui ont
été décentralisés pour financement pour
financer les pme c'est prendre le risque
de fragiliser le financement des pme que
de les re centralisée et je voudrais
ajouter en outre que les ressources qui
sont actuellement centralisés à la
caisse des dépôts est suffisent pour
couvrir les besoins en termes de
financement du logement social et donc
pour ces deux raisons à la fois la
priorité qui doit être attaché au
financement des pme et le fait que les
ressources aujourd'hui sont suffisantes
pour financer le logement social est
bien m'amène à rejeter votre amendement
je voudrais vous donner un exemple d'une
application d'une partie de votre moment
ci devait être adoptée relevé le plein
le plancher de centralisation
tel que vous le proposer dans votre
amendement conduit potentiellement à une
diminution de 15 milliards d'euros les
sommes disponibles pour le financement
des pme ce qui est évidemment
considérable et bien sûr il ne faut pas
adopter votre amendement je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
chers collègues monsieur vous souhaitez
répondre à l'appel de monsieur le
rapporteur
oui j'ai bien pris note de toutes les
remarques sur le rapporteur et celle de
vos sionisme notre une appréciation
différente entre entre les deux bien
entendu et en conséquence je maintiens
mon amendement nous allons consulter
madame riz vous savez la parole
cette occasion la de l'amendement
observé faire remarquer qu'au 30 31
décembre 2008 l'encours centralisées
auprès de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations était inférieur à ce qui
devait être le plancher qui devait
conduire à ce que 70 % des encours soit
centralisé c'était ça la loi de
modernisation de l'économie
et il n'a été il me semble que de 67 ou
68 % et coût 30 avril ce chiffre est
encore inférieur donc je pense que
l'engagement qui avait été pris dans la
loi de modernisation de l'économie n'est
pas respectée
c'est une des motivations qui conduiront
le groupe socialiste a demandé une
évaluation complète de la loi de
modernisation de l'économie à l'automne
quand
dans l'appel dans le cadre de la
procédure d'évaluation des lois qui ont
été votées ce n'est pas la seule mais
c'est une des éléments que nous voulons
regarder de près monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez la parole dès lors qu'on vote
sur le texte de la commission on ne voit
plus les améliorations apportées par
celle ci mais vous les connaissez
puisque vous y siéger vous y est
particulièrement active
donc nous avons ajouté deux choses
premièrement ont prévu que la
méconnaissance sur un trimestre de
l'obligation de centralisation sera
sanctionnée de l'obligation
d'affectation sera sanctionnée à la fois
par une centralisation à la caisse des
dépôts des ressources considéré et par
une pénalité financière pendant une
période équivalente de trois mois ce
régime tient compte du rythme
trimestriel du rapport d'euros au
ministre chargé de l'économie auquel
sont tenus les établissements concernés
d'autres pannes sont prévues
quand un tel cas la pénalité financière
consiste expressément dans la suspension
de la rémunération des fonds centralisés
à la caisse des dépôts
à la suite du constat de leur emploi non
conforme aux exigences légales
en d'autres termes nous avons complété
le dispositif assemblées nationales
liées à une initiative de monsieur
balligand et nous avons rendu cette
initiative opératoire je remercie
monsieur le rapporteur je consulte ceux
qui sont favorables à un amendement
présenté par monsieur verra veulent bien
levé lama avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté le 3 bis même vote
nous passons il est adopté oui par le
fonds
nous trois bis et adopté nouvelles sont
à l'article 4 monsieur verra vous
présenté d'amendements 4 rectifié s'il
vous plaît oui monsieur le président la
situation économique préoccupante de
votre pays se traduit pour le moment par
une récession ou marquer le gouvernement
vient d'annoncer que l'année 2009 serait
marquée par une récession de 3 points du
pib récession conduisant à l'explosion
du nombre des sans emplois avec comme on
le sait l'inscription d'un minimum de
six cent quarante mille chômeurs
supplémentaires et dans ses hypothèses
économiques le gouvernement mise sur une
légère reprise en 2010 reprises
atteignant le niveau de 0 5%
cette prévision de croissance en 2010
intègre l'amélioration relative de la
situation de nos banques et ce
redressement apparent la situation
financière de nos banques seraient liées
à nos yeux à la reconstitution de marge
qui a suivi la réduction du loyer de
l'argent sous l'impact des décisions
successives de baisse du taux directeur
de la bce est le fait que cet allègement
des coûts de crédit interbancaire n'a
pas eu de véritables répercussions sur
le niveau des taux d'intérêt il importe
si l'on veut effectivement créer les
conditions de la relance de l'activité
de mettre à disposition des pme des
ressources peu coûteuse et en
l'occurrence adossé à la collecte des
livrets de développement durable
cette solution est d'ailleurs moins
coûteuse pour les finances publiques
l'une des solutions retenues par le
gouvernement et qui vise depuis la loi
tepa à favoriser l'investissement des
particuliers dans les pme au travers de
la mobilisation des cotisations de l'
isf notre amendement vise donc à porter
à 9000 euros le plafond
versements sur les livrets de
développement durable en vue de
faciliter une relance de la collecte
d'un coût marginal pour les finances
publiques
cette mesure est porteuse d'effets
levier important d'autant que les
conditions de centralisation de la
collecte des livret d'epargne que nous
avons souligné précédemment peuvent
faciliter une meilleure allocation de la
ressource disponible
je remercie sûr que le monsieur le
rapporteur général président cet
amendement a été présenté en sciences de
la commission par monsieur verra qui en
est membre est rejetée par la commission
il revient en séance publique ce qui est
une redondance et ceci montre d'ailleurs
les limites de la procédure issue de la
révision constitutionnelle parce que si
un tel processus se répète indéfiniment
on ne voit pas bien à quoi ça sert de
tenir des séances de la commission en
présence d'un membre du gouvernement
avec un compte rendu qui permet aux uns
et aux autres d'expliciter leurs
initiatives et à la commission
d'expliciter ses avis je me permets de
souligner cela je n'y reviendrai pas la
vie est évidemment défavorable puisque
la commission a rejeté cet amendement
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement qui était
déjà été rejetées en commission
min il n'y a pas d'explications de vote
je consulte qui sont favorable à
l'amendement présenté par monsieur verra
qui est favorable qui est content il
n'est pas adoptée je consulte sur
l'article 4 qui est pour et qui est
contre et adoptée nous passons l'article
5 il y a deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
le président le premier présenté par
monsieur verra s'il vous plaît chez le
président
les chiffres de l'observatoire du crédit
publiée sur le site du ministère des
finances et de l'emploi démontre que les
données concernant les encours de
crédits et les nouveaux crédits
consentis aux entreprises sont
disponible mensuellement
cette qualité de l'information en
évitant toute interprétation trop
statique permet d'envisager que nous
disposions des outils de prévention et
de connaissance des difficultés d'accès
au crédit des entreprises
ce rythme mensuel permet de suivre avec
précision les évolutions du crédit et
d'anticiper tout changement
d'orientation et donc par cet amendement
nous proposons que la banque de france
publie mensuellement et non
trimestriellement
comme il est prévu à l'article 5 les
encours de crédits et les nouveaux
crédits consentis aux entreprises
je remercie chers collègues l'amendement
de rectifiée présentée par monsieur
arthuis ce monsieur le président vous
avez la parole présidant les chers
collègues le texte qui nous vient
l'assemblée nationale prévoit la
publication par la banque de france de
donner qui certainement sont
intéressantes mais il apparaît que la
banque de france n'est pas en situation
de rendre opérante les dispositions que
nous nous proposons de voter
par conséquent cet amendement revient
dans le champ de la faisabilité
je reconnais que ça n'est pas très
satisfaisant car après tout le
législateur est souverain pour fixer les
objectifs et demandé aux opérateurs de
s'y conformer mais dans le cas
particulier
je pense qu'il nous faut une expertise
complémentaire il semble que d'abord
dans l'immédiat ce n'est pas ça n'est
pas applicable et que pour satisfaire la
publication des données statistiques sur
les crédits nouveaux
il faudrait également un investissement
assez considérable s'il faut à
l'investissement considérable
naturellement c'est une pénalité il faut
bien ton mesuré l'opportunité donc voilà
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
déposé cet amendement
je souhaite pour ma part qu'il puisse
être voté pour que nous ayons un texte
différent de celui voté par l'assemblée
nationale et que la navette puisse se
poursuivre afin de permettre une
meilleure expertise et de statuer en
pleine connaissance de cause sur la
faisabilité de ce que nous votons je
vous remercie monsieur le président avis
de la commission sur le président je lis
sur une fois n'est pas coutume je ne
serais pas d'accord avec cette
intervention président jean arthuis
alors l'amendement
l'amendement au numéro 5 est vertueux
dans son principe vise à assurer une
plus grande transparence soulève deux
difficultés
d'une part il me semblait que l'article
5 dans son état imposant déjà la banque
de france une adaptation de son système
d'information et était de nature à
satisfaire au moins dans une large
mesure la préoccupation de monsieur vera
est au demeurant si je ne me trompe la
même rédaction avait été présenté en
commission le 27 mai par madame nicole
bricq qui avait considéré que le texte
proposé fait que le texte de l'article 5
finalement lui donner satisfaction
par ailleurs la publication des encours
de crédit ne peut en principe s'exercer
de manière agrégée dans la mesure où les
données fournies par chaque
établissement bancaire sont protégés par
le secret des affaires et le secret
statistique est obligé chaque réseau a
publié ses statistiques en la matière
pourrait nuire à ses intérêts
économiques
c'est donc en vertu de ces deux séries
de considération que j'émets un avis
défavorable maintenant sur l'amendement
arthuis pour faire vivre la navette
naturellement faire vivre la navette est
toujours une excellente chose mais
lorsqu'au prescrit une obligation à un
organisme est que cet organisme tire
prétexte de ses habitudes de travail
pour dire qu'il ne peut pas y déferré et
j'ai un peu plus de peine à suivre le
raisonnement par ce qu est la limite
il suffirait quand une prescription est
faite à un outil du secteur public ou de
l'administration que celui ci puisse
faire étape je ne sais quelle raison
issus de de ses méthodes de travail ici
de son système informatique
un autre jour du climat social pour dire
qu'il n'est pas en mesure de faire ce
qu'on lui demande de faire et
par ailleurs et se contenter
d'information sur les stocks de crédit
ne répond en rien aux préoccupations
exprimées dans la proposition de loi
alors on peut faire des propos tribune
sur les pme mais le peu qu'il y a de
concret de précis dans cette proposition
de loi
si on le vide à mon avis ça ne ça ne va
pas tout à fait dans le sens dans le
sens de ceux de ce texte bon ce n'est
pas une question est évidemment d'une
dune d'une importance stratégique ou ou
décisif naturellement mais elle est
quand même suffisamment délicate pour
qu'en commission de 27 mai nous nous
soyons partagée et que l'amendement
quand il s'agit de jean jacques jégou et
été repoussée avec égalité des voix
voilà alors bon je je je je comprends
bien et j'ajoute que le gouvernement
s'en était remis à la sagesse de la
commission alors vous avez maintenant
tous les éléments d'appréciation alors
ce qui me concerne je réitère un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre sur ces deux
amendements alors sur l'amendement
proposé par monsieur verra les
explications du rapporteur rejoigne
celle que j'aurais fait donc j'y suis
défavorable sur l'amendement présenté
par monsieur g ou et bien arthuis et
arthuis
mais je ne cherchais je le retrouve à la
présidence ne voyait pas n'essayez pas
de m'influencer monsieur le président en
excipant de votre poste bon tout a été
dit ou presque par à la fois par jean
arthuis et par philippe parini
l'amendement vise à retirer de la
publication la donne et des nouveaux
crédits
c'est vrai que la banque de france a
attiré l'attention sur l'inadaptation de
son système de collecte actuelle à
l'élaboration de cette donnée si elle
est en mesure d'établir les encours pour
différentes catégories d'entreprises la
banque centrale n'a pas à l'heure
actuelle
à l'heure actuelle les moyens de calcul
et la production de crédit durant une
période donnée
et c'est vrai que la mise en oeuvre
d'une telle disposition pourrait
nécessiter un délai long et ralentir
ainsi l'application de l'article 5 dans
son intégralité et donc comme je suis
d'une très grande cohérence sur mes
positions
mon étant remis à la sagesse de la
commission il ya quelques jours je m'en
remets à la sagesse de la haute
assemblée en ce moment bien jour mieux
film jules miss nous allons consulter
pardon amel emric non je vais la parole
en commission effectivement j'avais
déposé le même amendement que notre
collègue verra mais je les retire est et
à la lecture attentive de l'article 5
qui nous arrivait de l'assemblée
nationale et en présentant le débat qui
allait y avoir au sein de la commission
qui effectivement abouti à un partage et
une fois n'est pas coutume j'ai mis ma
voix à avec celle du rapporteur général
parce que
le texte qui nous arrivait de
l'assemblée prévoyez effectivement que
ce soit la banque de france qui
établisse ses données à la fois sur les
stocks et ce qui est très important sur
les flux de nouveaux crédits parce que
c'est bien de ça dont nous avons besoin
dans la période
donc je maintiens ma position à savoir
que j'appuierai la position de la
commission à laquelle le gouvernement a
donné un avis de sagesse parce que si
nous n'avons pas la possibilité et le
législateur l'a fait son travail de
vérifier les flux
c'est à dire les nouveaux crédits nous
sommes complètement dépourvu de la
possibilité de transparence ce qui était
quand même l'esprit de la proposition de
loi notamment dans cette période de
crise et nous avons tous dit les uns et
les autres
même ceux qui soutiennent l'action du
gouvernement tous j'ai bien entendu les
orateurs qui se sont succédé qu'il y a
un problème que nous constatons tous les
jours d'accès au crédit des pme dans les
entreprises
alors qu'elles ont que les banques ont
reçu je le répète pas des dotations
quand même extrêmement importante et ça
ne se matérialise pas et nos collègues
du groupe crc en raison elles sont en
train de reconstituer leurs marges
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
donc il faut pouvoir le vérifier avec un
outil statistique fiable
si madame laure je vais consulter sur
l'amendement numéro 5 présentée par
monsieur verra la commission et
gouvernement sont défavorables qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée sur l'amendement présenté par
monsieur jego et en suisse la commission
est défavorable et le gouvernement s'en
remet à la sagesse de la haute assemblée
alors qui est favorable
qui est contre
b il n'est pas adopté je consulte sur
l'article 5 qui est pour sûr le 5 bis
même vote adoptée cinqueterre 5 waters
et 6
artix ibis adopter s'il n'y a pas de
l'opposition
après l'article 6 bis je suis saisi d'un
amendement présenté par monsieur
philippe dominati vous avez la parole
sur collègues
merci monsieur le président avec cet
amendement monsieur ministre il s'agit
d' amplifier le succès que connaît le
déploiement du régime de l'auto
entrepreneur et notamment en outre mer
en appliquant le taux de cotisation
sociale spécifique en tenant compte des
cotisations prévalant dans ces
territoires
cet amendement permet la mise en oeuvre
de taux spécifiques en cas de cumul
entre le régime micro social simplifié
prévu à l'article l133 du code de la
sécurité sociale et l'exonération prévue
aux articles l 756 4 et l 756 5 pour les
travailleurs indépendants exerçant dans
les dom je vous remercie
avis de la commission tout à fait
intéressant qui étend le champ
d'application de l'article
caveirac finances rectificative pour
2009 et qui à l'initiative du
gouvernement et avec notre avis
favorable avait prévu la mise en place
de ce dispositif en métropole il
s'agissait de ne pas priver les
bénéficiaires de l'accre de la
possibilité d'accéder au statut d'auto
entrepreneur ainsi dans le cas d'une
activité commerciale en prélèvement
social est fixé à 12 % le taux
forfaitaire de cotisations des buts à 3
% la première année puis 6% et 9%
les deux années suivantes il convient
d'approuver cette extension à
l'outre-mer du régime de l'auto
entrepreneur qui a déjà fait l'objet
d'un avis favorable de la commission
toutefois il faut s'interroger sur le
coût de la disposition matière
d'outre-mer on n'est jamais trop prudent
de ce côté là et par conséquent et par
conséquent par conséquent il serait
utile d'entendre le gouvernement le
ministre suit je suis monsieur le
président favorable à l'amendement
proposé et je lèverai le gage la
détermination des taux applicables aux
auto entrepreneurs dans les dom
préservera l' équilibre financier de la
mesure ses taux et bien je peux vous
indiquer que ils seront fixés aux deux
tiers des taux normaux pratiquer selon
les différentes spécifications de l'auto
entrepreneur dans les activités de
commerce libéral ou de services ou de de
services donc favorable élevé du gage en
porter général position est identique
bien alors je me vois l'amendement
numéro 8 présentée par monsieur dominati
dont le gouvernement annoncé qu'il level
le gage qui est favorable à l'amendement
numéro 8
gouvernement et pour la commission et
peuvent très bien m'écouter pas monsieur
trucy qui est contre l'amendement est
adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 13 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur dominati vous
avez la parole merci monsieur président
avec mon ami gérard longuet par cet
amendement nous avons voulu préciser le
traitement comptable de l'écart de
valorisation qui peut exister lors de la
cession d'une société par rachat de ses
salariés avec création d'une société
coopérative ouvrière de production
c'est-à-dire une scop prévues par les
articles 48 et suivants de la loi de
cet écart de valorisation peut être
inscrit à l'actif du bilan selon des
modalités fixées par un règlement de
l'autorité des normes comptables qui
devra préciser en particulier les
conditions applicables pour justifier
l'existence de plus values latentes
ainsi valorisé et le suivi qui sera
nécessaire avec notamment la possibilité
de procéder à des dépréciations gros
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
ministre il est vrai que la
transformation d'une société en société
coopérative ouvrière de production ne
fait pas l'objet jusqu'ici de
dispositions comptables particulière il
existe une doctrine édité par la
confédération générale des scop et qui
préconise de comptabiliser l'écart de
valorisation n'est de la transformation
dans un conte d'ordre à l'actif
toutefois ce traitement comptable a été
remise en cause sur la base d'une
analyse menée conjointement avec la
coopération avec la confédération des
scop
le conseil national de la comptabilité a
conclu qu'ils n'étaient pas possibles en
application des textes comptables
actuelles d'inscrire le dit écart à
l'actif
par conséquent seul l'adoption dans la
loi de règles comptables spécifiques
fyk aux sociétés coopératives ouvrières
de production pourrait permettre de
valider le principe reconnu jusqu'ici
par la doctrine et qui prévoit
l'inscription de l'écart et de
comptabilisation à l'actif cet
amendement répondantes à un tel besoin
la commission y est favorable
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le
gouvernement est lui aussi favorable à
l'amendement présenté par gérard longuet
et par philippe dominati
car cet amendement comme l'a rappelé
monsieur le rapporteur précise utilement
le traitement comptable de l'écart de
valorisation qui peut exercer lors de la
cession d'une société par rachat de ses
salariés avec création d'une société
coopérative ouvrière de production
cet amendement adopté permettra de
faciliter la reprise de sociétés par les
salariés en recause en recourant à des
scop
le gouvernement y est donc favorable je
suis monsieur me soulever le gage gage
élevé je vous remercie pas d'explication
de vup ceux qui sont favorables à un
moment très actif y est présentée par
monsieur dominati vague b relevé lama
avis contraire il est adopté jeu confus
y'a pas sur l'article 6 ter pas
d'opposition l'antique lé 6 quater
également l'article 6 qu'inquiets ce
nous pressons ensuite un amendement
présenté par messieurs de montgolfier
béteille les membres du groupe ump c'est
monsieur dominati qu'il présente
j'adore les i dans cet amendement vise à
exempter les experts comptables de
déclaration de soupçon lorsqu'il donne
des consultations juridiques
il permet ainsi de rétablir
dans le cadre du jean du nouveau
dispositif de lutte contre le
blanchiment des capitaux et le
financement du terrorisme
leur précédente obligation déclarative
auprès du service tracfin en préservant
leur secret professionnel dans le cadre
de leur activité de conseil juridique
cette modification répond à une forte
demande des professionnels en ce sens
cet amendement est conforme au principe
d'égalité de traitement devant la loi il
aligne en effet le régime déclaratif des
experts comptables sont celui applicable
aux professions juridiques dans le cadre
de leurs activités de consultation
juridique
il rétablit ainsi une égalité de
traitement entre ces professionnels
s'agissant d'activité identique
cet amendement permet par ailleurs aux
agents des services de l'état chargés de
la mise en oeuvre des mesures de gel des
avoirs de recevoir de l'administration
des impôts
tous les renseignements nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de ses missions non
seulement dans le cadre du gel des
avoirs terroriste prévues par le code
monétaire et financier mais aussi dans
le cadre du gel des avoirs liés aux
sanctions financières internationales
prévues par le même code
merci monsieur 2010 monsieur le
rapporteur
cet amendement a pour but essentiel
comme on l'a compris des lignes et en
matière de lutte anti blanchiment
le régime déclaratif des experts
comptables sur celui des avocats déjà en
vigueur
oui bien entendu
cela paraît clair ces mêmes limpide cher
monsieur le président c'est limpide
et parce que les experts comptables ce
sont des entreprises et les avocats
aussi bon donc nous restons dans le
domaine des entreprises et il s'agit de
certaines activités devant alors les
experts comptables serait ainsi exemptés
de la déclaration de soupçon à tracfin
lorsqu'il donne des consultations
juridiques sauf si celle ci était donnée
à des fins de blanchiment de capitaux ou
de financement du terrorisme
l'amendement et aurait aussi pour
finalité de permettre aux agents des
services de l'état de recevoir de
l'administration des impôts toutes les
informations nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de leur mission
que ce soit dans le cadre du gel des
avoirs terroriste légalement dans le
cadre du gel des avoirs liés aux
sanctions financières internationales ça
c'est un second aspect qui est de
caractère beaucoup plus technique alors
la commission qui effectivement est
sensible à la symétrie s'en remettre à
l'avis du gouvernement voilà merci
monsieur mini bien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
bien le gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement
c'est un amendement d'équité qui est
particulièrement bienvenue s'agissant de
la modification du régime déclaratif des
experts comptables parce que la mort la
modification envisagée comme l'a
parfaitement expliqué le sénateur
dominati permettra d'aligner leur régime
déclaratif sur celui applicable aux
professions juridiques dans le cadre de
leurs activités de consultation
elles rétablissent cet amendement est
bien rétabli ainsi une égalité de
traitement entre ces professionnels
s'agissant d'activité identique fisea
donc parfaitement favorable je vous
remercie
s'il ya des explications de vote mais
ben brik oui je réitère
devant la séance de ce soir la position
que nous avons adopté en commission des
finances
franchement par les temps qui courent où
on nous dit que de sommet international
en sommet international tous les efforts
sont faits pour lutter contre le
blanchiment
l'intitulé du grand 4 les experts
comptables ne sont pas soumis aux
dispositions de la section 4 du présent
chapitre qu'il donne des consultations
juridiques et cetera et cetera
c'est pas acceptable et l'argument de
l'équité
masque en fait l'accès à une demande
réitérée d'une profession bien
identifiés bon j'utilise pas l'argument
de corporatisme
mais franchement si les experts
constatent comptable veulent faire des
consultations juridiques ils deviennent
avocats
je vous remercie chers collègues il n'y
a pas d'autres explications de vote
je consulte sur l'amendement 9 rectifier
le gouvernement est favorable la
commission également ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopter cet amendement va bien
levé lama s'il vous plaît avis contraire
il est adopté
nous passons maintenant à l'amendement
numéro 1 présenté par madame briques
défendu avis de la commission
défavorable nos ministres
je consulte sur cet amendement
numéro 1 présenté par madame briques et
les membres du groupe socialiste qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée sur la non qui n'est pas adoptée
n'y a pas d'article si c'est sur
l'article 6 ex yes section ac et pour
qui et contre est adoptée sur l'article
6 etc csb nouveau même vote sur
l'article 6 sections même bug sur
l'article 6 70 nouveaux mais butt après
l'article si ces pièces
un amendement de messieurs et richement
et dominati c'est vous qui présentait
monsieur dominati tout à fait monsieur
le président merci beaucoup
le développement du trades du très haut
débit c'est à dire des réseaux en fibre
optique est un objectif prioritaire du
gouvernement qui en fait un axe majeur
de sa politique dans le numérique pour
obtenir
eux de faire en sorte que 4 millions
d'abonnés à l'horizon de 2012 puissent
en bénéficier
à cet effet la loi de modernisation de
l'économie a posé un certain nombre de
principes fondamentaux notamment
l'article 109 qui prévoit ainsi le pré
équipement en fibre optique des
immeubles neufs à compter de 2010
cet article pose également le principe
de la mutualisation entre les opérateurs
de la partie terminale des réseaux en
fibre optique
les principes posés par la lmr est
pertinent mais la mise en oeuvre
pratique de la mutualisation fait
apparaître un grand nombre de questions
techniques et opérationnels complexes
sur le plan technique deux solutions
existent
le mono fibre qui consiste à établir une
seule fibre optiques dans chaque
logement fibre pouvant être utilisé par
tout opérateur desservant ce logement
le multi fibres dans lequel plusieurs
fibres optiques sont établis dans chaque
logement chaque opérateur pouvant ainsi
disposer de sa propre fibre une
expérimentation lancée fin 2008 par le
secrétaire d'état à l'économie numérique
est piloté par l'arcep été conduite de
janvier à avril 2009
les conclusions de cette expérimentation
de ces diverses expérimentations indique
selon l'arcep que le schéma multifibre
est approprié au déploiement de la fibre
optique dans le cas de la france il est
donc nécessaire de préciser le
dispositif législatif en vigueur pour
permettre à ce schéma des mises en
oeuvre par les opérateurs sous le
contrôle de l'autorité de régulation
team sur le rapporteur ce tas mandement
mes chers collègues est très important
pour tous les copropriétaires de france
monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur général et les
locataires mais il arrive sans crier
gare à la fin de la discussion d'une
proposition de loi dont l'objet est à
cent lieues de l'ain je regrette la
commission des finances qui rapporte ce
texte n'a aucune compétence aucune
antériorité en la matière ce sujet est
un sujet excellemment traités par la
commission des affaires économiques et
il me paraîtrait bien préférable de lui
laisser faire son travail jusqu'au bout
alors sauté sur le véhicule législatif
qui passe
ça fait preuve d'une belle agilité ceci
étant dit est ce véritablement de bonne
méthode
est-ce véritablement de bonne méthode
alors monsieur le ministre
vraiment les mesures dont il s'agit non
non pas de lien avec le crédit aux pme
enfin je cherche je cherche le lien mais
dans alors bon c'est bon bon
alors bon il s'agit d'établir des liens
entre des pme c'est ça bon alors mais
est ce que ceci est lié au financement
des entreprises
alors mais là je vois que la présidence
est temps d'engager un banc alors non on
n'est pas bon alors donc sans doute
est-ce une excellente idée mais
sincèrement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission des finances n'a pas été
en mesure de se livrer à une étude
sérieuse de cette situation toutefois
j'ai reçu des observations dont je sais
bien qu elles ne sont pas neutres mais
il yad un côté l'autorité de régulation
de l'autre l'opérateur historique et les
uns et les autres se fonde sur des
argumentaires juridiques et techniques
très élaboré des pages de jurisprudence
des pages serrées de droit communautaire
de droit national comment à cette
heure-ci à la fin de ce débat pour étant
donné une réponse sérieuse sur ce sujet
même si la cause est excellente même si
la cause est excellente
alors il me semble qu'il vaudrait mieux
écouter le gouvernement puis
éventuellement reprendre cette
disposition
après qu'elle soit retirée dans un texte
qui constituerait un support plus
indiqué monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vais tenter de clarifier le
débat tout en entendant ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur général sur les amendements
qui sont des amendements très important
et qui arrive opportunément où selon
certains de manière inopportune mais qui
en tout cas on le mérite de poser des
vrais débats je voudrais essayer de nous
rassembler sur quelques constats clair
d'abord un le développement du très haut
débit
c'est à dire des réseaux en fibre
optique c'est un objectif majeur un
objectif prioritaire bien sûr du
gouvernement qui en a fait un des axes
du plan france numérique 2012 c'est
aussi je le crois a un objectif de
l'ensemble des sénateurs rassemblés ici
afin d'atteindre au moins 4 millions
d'abonnés en france d'ici 2012 il est
nécessaire de mettre en place un cadre
réglementaire favorable à
l'investissement des opérateurs privés
tout en permettant la concurrence entre
eux au bénéfice des consommateurs
à cet effet la loi de modernisation de
l'économie a posé un certain nombre de
principes fondamentaux l'article 109
prévoit ainsi le pré équipement en fibre
optique des immeubles neufs à compter de
2010 cet article pose également le
principe de la mutualisation entre les
opérateurs de la partie terminale des
réseaux en fibre optique
alors j'entends bien que le sénat n'est
pas complètement informés des aspects
technique car dans les faits deux
solutions existent pour le pré
équipement en fibre optique des
immeubles deux solutions existent
le mono fibre qui consiste à établir une
seule fibre optiques dans chaque
logement fibre pouvant être ensuite
utilisé par tout opérateur c'est la
mutualisation d'une fibre et puis une
autre solution qui est la multifibre
dans lequel plusieurs fibres optiques
sont établis dans chaque logement
ces deux solutions techniques ont été
comme l'a rappelé le sénateur philippe
dominati ont été expérimentées elles ont
été expérimentés tout au long de des
premiers mois de 2009
les conclusions de ces expérimentations
indique que le schéma multifibre comme
le schéma mono-fibre fonctionne les deux
solutions techniques fonctionnent et
donc peuvent servir pour le déploiement
de la fibre optique en france
hélas moment de philippe dominati
en fait offre la liberté de choix permet
la liberté de choix entre les deux
options techniques
c'est ça le fond de l'amendement de
philippe dominati et un amendement qui
permet une avancée en n'imposant pas en
imposant tas et j insiste une solution
technique au profit de tel ou tel
opérateur me semble tout à fait
intéressante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'y suis bien sûr tout à fait
favorable y at-il un lien maintenant
avec le texte qui nous préoccupe et bien
je le crois car faire en sorte que nous
puissions par la liberté des choix
techniques accélérer le déploiement de
la fibre optique dans les immeubles
mais dans les immeubles il y a bien sûr
les gens qui y vivent mais les gens qui
est vide
ce sont souvent des entrepreneurs
installés à leur domicile
k
je vous rappelle je vous rappelle je
vous rappelle ici si je peux continuer
mon propos je voudrais vous indiquer que
depuis des années nous faisons en sorte
de factiva de faciliter l'activité y
compris au domicile de ceux qui
déclarent leurs activités nous avons
adopté des dispositions législatives en
ce sens et je vous renvoie à la loi de
modernisation de l'économie pour les
professions pour les professionnels
indépendants les entrepreneurs
indépendants
vous le savez nous avons permis dans le
cadre de la loi de modernisation la
domiciliation dans le lieu de domicile
de l'entrepreneur individuel et avec le
succès vous faites bien de me faire
souvenirs madame le sénateur car je vous
ai entendu dans mon oreille gauche avec
le succès de l'auto entrepreneur qui se
déclare dans son lieu de domicile
c'est près de 200000 auto entrepreneurs
qui se sont déclarés eh bien ces deux
cent mille auto entrepreneurs qui
exercent chez eux leur activité je suis
persuadé qu'ils sont très intéressés à
la solution à l'option de liberté de
choix qui est permise par cet amendement
est donc le gouvernement est favorable à
cet amendement est vous demande de le
suivre pour permettre le déploiement de
la fibre optique dans notre pays
madame briques vous avez la parole chers
collègues je remercie ensuite je suis
pas du tout spécialiste de la fibre
optique mais je faisais partie de la
commission spéciale qui avait été mise
en place au moment du débat sur la loi
de modernisation de l'économie et je me
suis renseigné auprès notamment de mes
collègues de la commission économie très
très au fait de ses problèmes alors je
voudrais quand même faire remarquer
qu'avec cet amendement on est très loin
des pme c'est quand même un cavalier il
faut le dire
et il faut aussi dire pour que tout le
monde soit éclairé qu'il s'agit en fait
de répondre à une demande d'un opérateur
pour ne pas le nommer
free qui veut disposer de sa propre
fibre optique
c'était le débat que nous avons eu il ya
un an dans la commission spéciale et
l'amendement que nous proposent nos
collègues hérisson dominati reviendrai
sur ce qui a été décidé dans la loi de
modernisation de l'économie il faut
quand même le dire
il revient il revient dessus parce que
ce n'est pas le choix qui avait été
effectué à l'époque alors je reprends
pas l'argumentation qui avait fait que
cette solution n'avait pas été retenu
mais on passe si j'ai bien compris les
explications techniques du ministre on
revient on passerait d'un système de
mono fibre un système obligeant les
opérateurs à déployer des fibres
surnuméraires on est bien d'accord
donc ça entraîne ça entraîne un surcoût
ça c'est évident pour alors tous ces
arguments viennent en balance avec un
autre argument qui va un peu en sens
contraire c'est l'intérêt à ouvrir
largement l'accès au réseau
c'est ça que vous de vous développer
alors moi je suis un peu d'accord être
le rapporteur franchement
on est là depuis le début de l'après
midi on a cet amendement il faut prendre
une position le gouvernement est plutôt
favorable on nous dit aussi que l'arcep
il serait favorable
si j'ai bien entendu les arguments
développés par les uns et par les autres
bon bon on a pas d'opposition al voter
mais je suis pas sûr qu'on en mesure
toutes les conséquences
bon voilà mais on va on aura du mal à
par rapport à l'alimentation qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut effectivement
ouvrir largement l'accès au réseau il
pense on pense que ils en portent plutôt
sur l'aspect bon qui consiste à donner
droit à un opérateur c'est quand même
sac
1 et le débat avait porté là-dessus
l'année dernière donc on est plutôt
favorable voter ses passions c'est bien
mais c'est plutôt les indications qu'on
m'a donné monsieur le président mercier
merci vous êtes prêts je voudrais être
aussi bref que possible mais le bonnet à
deux observations à plusieurs reprises
ces derniers jours sénat a siégé sans
désemparer et beaucoup d'entre nous se
sont plaints des conséquences des
procédures nouvelles très bien on n'a
pas encore tous construits il faudra
travailler mais honnêtement et je
félicite le ministre pour les efforts
méritoires qu'il vient de faire devant
nous pour nous expliquer le lien qu'il y
avait entre cet amendement qu'il dépose
et on s'est compris et c'est en effet
une erreur une rapidité de langage que
j'ai utilisée pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse aller se coucher à cette eau
c'est c'est un raccourci est un
raccourci mais je félicite le ministre
d'avoir essayé de nous montrer le lien
qu'il y avait entre cet abonnement et le
texte qui à l'actif à l'accès au crédit
pm il est évident qu'il y a oui oui mais
on pourrait en effet moi je moi je
serais pas hostile à ce qu'on mette
robichaud loi relative à diverses
dispositions intéressantes
ce qui aurait un champ suffisamment
large puis pour qu'on puisse aller au
bout il ya quand même un vrai problème
on est en train de patauger un peu dans
la procédure nouvelle
on s'envoie beaucoup et si nous même si
nous mêmes ne sommes pas capables de
nous discipliner un petit peu ça pose un
vrai problème sur le fond
moi je suis très favorable au
développement de la fibre optique
mais ce qui serait bien c'est vrai
ministre c'est que on écrive peut-être
en français cet amendement
la première phrase fait est un titre
quelques lignes et demi et très
honnêtement moi je comprends pas ce
qu'on veut dire deuxième paragraphe ya
deux phrases une de quatre lignes une
deux trois lignes et demi je comprends
pas non plus que ce qu'elle amène et si
j'ai bien compris pourquoi j'ai bien
compris ce que vous aviez dit vous avez
dit il ya une obligation de pré
équipement des bâtiments nouveaux et je
regrette donc de vous dire que votre
argument 10 ans il ya deux cent mille
auto-entrepreneurs qui habite dans ses
habits l'immeuble c'est un peu faux
puisqu'ils sont pas construits et il
habite dans l'est l'autre dans ceux qui
sont là bûcher de l'abonnement et encore
personne puisqu'ils sont pas construits
mais deuxième observation
deuxième observation vous nous avez dit
il ya deux solutions et la loi c'est un
moment permet de prendre l'une ou
l'autre et a donc aucun objet normatif
que s'il ya deux solutions
et qu'ont-ils fait voter une loi pour
dire on prend l'une ou l'autre bassin
mc2 on pensait le qu'on veut il ya pas
besoin doit donc je ne vois pas bien
l'utilité de ce texte
pratique pratique et puis si vous
pouviez faire écrire en français pour
qu'on puisse voter ce serait bien parce
que très honnêtement
parce que quand on mène écrit toute
personne établie sens où il a établi
dans un immeuble matthew qui soit à une
lignes de communications électroniques à
très haut débit en fibre optique
permettant de servir un utilisateur
final fait droit aux demandes
raisonnables d'accès à la victime et aux
moyens qui sont associés maintenant
d'opérateurs en vue de fournir des
services de communications électroniques
à cet utilisateur final
très honnêtement moi je ne comprends pas
ce que ça veut dire et je veux bien
voter n'importe quoi ça m'est déjà
arrivé mais j'aimerais autant savoir que
voilà donc moi je pense qu'un petit peu
de travail autour de ce texte s'impose
remercie monsieur le président monsieur
biver mais c'est le mi6 auraient la
parole après je me suis dominati est
également présidente ministre dans mon
intervention tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
ce problème en ayant je crois un peu de
crainte que l'on tente de nous faire
aller un peu vite
moi j'ai participé aussi aux travaux de
la commission lme nous avons fait
différentes réunions différents
déplacements et il était bien précisé
que toute possibilité était garantie
dans le cadre justement de la
mutualisation possible de la fibre et
c'était semble-t-il un acte positif qui
intervenait dans la loi et dans cette
décision en précisant combien chacun
pourrait apporter sa pierre à la
contribution quelque chose qui pour une
fois créé un peu d'unité autour d'un
grand service le deuxième point c'est
que moi j'en suis encore à essayer
d'obtenir l'adsl dans mon propre bureau
je vois pas comment je vais aller
expliqué chez moi que on va faire des
doubles fibre optique alors qu'on nous
oppose toute possibilité d'obtenir ce le
minimum dont nous avons besoin pour ne
servir de nous tiens pour ma
informatique dans de bonnes conditions
alors c'est pourquoi the mist je vous
inviterai à venir expliquer ça mais je
ne peux pas comprendre que l'on veuille
une fois de plus s'occuper d'une manière
particulière des endroits où la
population est dense en laissant tomber
le reste du territoire est en nous
racontant tous les matins que 99 et demi
pour cent du territoire est desservie ne
savons très bien que c'est pas vrai et
nous savons très bien comment nous
vivons dans nos campagnes
alors tout ça mais me conduis moi aussi
à dire combien les il serait intéressant
d'inviter plus tôt l'arcep c'est ce qui
lui demande d'intervenir en la
circonstance de se regrouper avec les
opérateurs pour véritablement utilisée
en commun quelque chose qui sera clair
au moins en matière d'organisation et
qui sera efficace sur le sur le plan
pratique c'est pourquoi
personnellement je me refuse à voter ce
texte cher collègue monsieur dominati
dernier orateur gédé le gouvernement
suit répondre oui je voulais monsieur le
président à apporter quelques précisions
je m'excuse peut-être pour les problèmes
de rédaction et de style mais lorsqu'on
fait un travail collectif et que comme
c'est l'ensemble du groupe auquel
j'appartiens qui présente cet amendement
c'est un amendement qui répond à la
technicité voulue par l'arcep
il est vrai qu'en l'occurrence on a été
peut-être très réactif c'est à dire que
comme adam lerrick l'a souligné lors de
la loi elle émeut divers dispositifs
entre le mono fibre et le multi-fibres
était proposé et il y avait une
difficulté à appréhender ce problème
technique
entre temps la recette a fait des
évaluations des concertations et des
épreuves à partir du moment où nous
avons les résultats de l'autorité de
régulation
il a semblé judicieux qu'au cours de
cette loi qui concerne quand même
l'économie dans la période dans laquelle
nous sommes que l'on s'adapte le plus
rapidement possible pour la construction
d'immeubles qui vont avoir lieu en 2010
on est toujours en train de compliquer
généralement
je dirais dans le domaine de la
faisabilité un certain nombre de
dispositions et la construction de
l'immeuble c'est pas quelque chose d
aimants facile on est à six mois de
l'échéance 2010
à partir du moment où nous avons une
précision technique d'une autorité de
régulation qui dit pour notre pays c'est
le choix c'est le choix après une
hésitation un débat qui a eu lieu il me
semblait évident avec les collègues de
mon groupe de profiter
effectivement de l'axé du crédit aux pme
pour résoudre ce problème dans cette loi
nous avons vu d'autres dispositions qui
ne sont pas non plus si proche de l'
objet direct de la loi du cher président
donc c'était l'objet de cet amendement
je pense que il est réactif il permet de
gagner du temps il permet d'éclaircir
très rapidement le débattent dans ce
domaine monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur a souhaité que la commission
s'exprime devant votre je prie de
m'excuser sur le président monsieur le
ministre
cette question qui est importante je
persiste à dire que nous ne sommes pas
en mesure de la traiter sérieusement ce
soir et quand je me réfère à la loi de
modernisation de l'économie elles à
moins d'un an le gouvernement est elle
même une expertise a été conduite et de
quoi s'agit-il
on nous dit dans l'exposé des motifs
qu'il s'agit de préciser le dispositif
législatif existant
or j'ai bien l'impression qu'il s'agit
d'aller bien au delà de simples
précision et sur un seul point
je voudrais
il insisté et le second paragraphe non
pas celui dont michel mercier nous a
donné lecture mais le suivant comporte
est un principe excellent l'accès est
fourni dans des conditions transparentes
et non discriminatoires en un point
situé parfait et ceci est bien
compréhensible mais il s'y ajoute
l'incident suivante sauf dans les cas
définis par l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes
bon donc le principe et son contraire et
on déléguerait à l'arcep une compétence
réglementaire total sans la guider pour
définir les cas d'exclusion en juriste
je suis amené à dire que ceci pose
problème est peut-être ce problème
peut-il être résolus mais encore faut-il
en débattre et en débattent dans une
enceinte appropriée donc pour pas de
manière improvisée en fin de discussion
d'un texte qui n'a pas cette finale it
je me permets lui dire monsieur le
ministre
tous nous nous nous nous conduit en
général à a sympathisé dans les mêmes
positions mais ici vraiment il y à des
considérations de méthode qui ne peuvent
pas ne pas être invoqué pour ma part je
je réitère un avis défavorable à
l'adoption
séance tenante de cet amendement jules
ministre bien je crois que l'ensemble
des sénateurs se sont exprimés
je voudrais pour ma part clarifier les
quelques
point qui reste encore à clarifier qui
ont été posées par les derniers
intervenants
je voudrais rappeler d'abord que la loi
de modernisation de l'économie a posé un
certain nombre de principes et je
voudrais indiquer que l'article 109 de
la loi de modernisation prévoit ainsi le
pré équipement en fibre optique des
immeubles neufs à compter de 2010
sur cela je crois que cette loi elle
existe elle a été votée par la haute
assemblée
et donc elle est je dirais indiscutable
mais l'article 109 pose également le
principe de la mutualisation entre les
opérateurs de la partie terminale des
réseaux en fibre optique et ce principe
de mutualisation
il est lui aussi inscrit dans la loi de
modernisation de l'économie
jusque là je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord sur le plan technique
et bien cette mutualisation elle peut
reposer sur les deux aspects techniques
que j'indiquais précédemment et les
expérimentations qui ont été menées nous
indique que les deux solutions
techniques sont également opérationnels
et l'amendement permet d'utiliser ces
deux options
autrement dit cet amendement n'impose
rien il ouvre une faculté de choix entre
les deux options techniques ce qui veut
dire que dire que cet amendement on est
très important certes il est important
par le sujet traité
mais surtout cet amendement il prend en
compte les derniers éléments qui nous
manquait pour préciser cet article 109
et précisé que les deux options
techniques de mutualisation sont
également opérationnels et c'est la
raison d'eux
ajout de l'amendement proposé par
philippe dominati
je crois que aujourd'hui il faut avoir
présent cette ambition du câblage il
faut savoir que il y a aujourd'hui une
ambition du gouvernement et de la
majorité
et j'en suis convaincue de de beaucoup
de sénateurs de cette ambition de la
fibre optique
voilà je ne vais pas maintenant refaire
la démonstration et et tentez de vous
démontrer le lien qui existe avec
l'activité des très petites entreprises
je ne le ferai pas je l' ai déjà fait
mais je voudrais maintenant aller au
fond et vous dire que cet amendement
offre une faculté de choix et que cette
faculté de choix n'est pas une
obligation qui nous permet de choisir
telle ou telle option technique
elles permettent de faire l'une ou
l'autre et il n'y a pas de raison
d'imposer un choix technique qui
réservent la possibilité pour tel
opérateur de bénéficier d'un avantage
évident en ce qui concerne sa capacité à
avoir une barrière qui empêche ce
déploiement accéléré que nous souhaitons
et que nous avons inscrit dans la loi de
la fibre optique
cet amendement n'est rien d'autre que
cela et je persiste à a donné l'option
favorable du gouvernement à cet
amendement assise sur les
expérimentations qui ont été menées et
et validé par l'autorité de régulation
jour merci monsieur le ministre at il
d'autres intervenants
monsieur le rapporteur sur le fond vous
êtes très éloquent très convaincant on
peut
se laisser convaincre mais du point de
vue de la constitution
il ya quand même deux choses qui sont
importantes y at-il un lien même
indirect soyons sérieux
regardons les choses de manière
objective avec le texte dont nous
débattons
en second lieu est ce que le législateur
et puis sa compétence
si l'on délègue à l'arcep le soin de
définir des exceptions sans guide et le
pouvoir réglementaire
nous prenons un second risque
constitutionnel sérieux est-ce que ça en
vaut la peine
est-ce qu'il faut que cette disposition
qui sans doute intéressante d'esprit
libéral est-ce qu'il faut que cette
disposition fasse l'objet soit d'un
rejet soit d'une contestation de sa
constitutionnalité
est-ce que ça en vaut la peine est ce
qu'il n'est pas préférable d'utiliser
les voies normales
c'est à dire d'en débattre au sein de la
commission compétente et dans un texte
approprié franchement c'est la question
devrait être posée en demandant in fine
et un philippe dominati de bien vouloir
retirer son amendement
alors ce n'est pas naturellement une
appréciation défavorable sur le fond
j'en serais bien incapable mais c'est en
vertu des considérations de méthode que
je viens de développer remercie monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur sido demande la
parole oui monsieur le président vous
l'ignorez probablement mais je m'occupe
aujourd'hui du grenelle 1 et du grenelle
2 nous allons avoir un travail en
commission demain et après-demain
travail très important mais j'allais
manger un sandwich à la buvette je passe
dans la salle des conférences
et quand ange qu'à l'occasion d'un débat
sur les caisses d'epargne quand ange pme
oui d'accord on parle de fibre optique
on parle de haut débit ils se trouvent
il se trouve que c'est un sujet qui me
passionne également j'étais d'ailleurs
rapporteur d'un certain nombre de lois
traitant de cette affaire-là
alors je dois dire très humblement que
je n'ai absolument aucun avis sur cet
amendement qui est déposée par nos
éminents collègues de mon groupe puisque
je crois qu'il est soutenu par tout
l'ump et maintenant je voudrais dire et
je rejoindrai le rapporteur de la loi
qui est débattue actuellement qu'il est
quand même étonnant que l'on puisse
encore démocratiquement déposer des
amendements purement cavaliers parce que
le véritable sujet cette fibre optique
et le développement du très haut débit
sur tout le territoire français devrait
de mon point de vue faire l'objet d'une
loi d'une loi d'un projet de loi ou
d'une proposition de loi
tout à fait particulière je suis sur têt
l'occasion du débat de ce type de loi il
y aurait beaucoup de monde dans
l'hémicycle alors traité à 9 à 21 heures
et quelques d'un amendement cavaliers
sur un sujet aussi important et qui ne
traitent qu'un tout petit une toute
petite partie de la question
c'est à dire la montée des étages dans
les immeubles
mais monsieur le ministre il ya tout le
monde tout le milieu rural et en tant
que président de conseil général je peux
vous dire que cette question ait
considérablement importante est que
grâce d'ailleurs à la clause générale de
compétence grâce à cette clause les
conseils généraux vont pouvoir équiper
notre territoire alors qu'il est
abandonné complètement par les
opérateurs par etc etc
par conséquent étant un membre fidèle
l'ump je propose à mon collègue que cet
amendement qui est arrivé sans que
personne ne soit au courant personnes
soit retirée je rejoins tout à fait
monsieur le rapporteur alphin qu'ils
soient discutées dans un cadre et dans
un contexte d'une proposition ou d'un
projet de loi qui fasse que chacun
puisse participer utilement au débat
voilà ma proposition en or si monsieur
sido je consulte ses présidents j'ai
bien entendu les conditions de travail
exceptionnelles dans lesquelles nous
travaillons mais je pense qu'il faut
être efficace et pragmatique et en
l'occurrence moi je souhaite désormais
que l'on passe au vote tout simplement
et si j'aurais on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler ultérieurement donc consulté
que ceux qui sont david adopté
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
dominati veille bien levé la main
ceux qui sont défavorables bien levé la
main l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous
passons maintenant à l'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement
après l'article si ces petits messieurs
le ministre vous avez la parole
c'est l'amendement numéro 14 monsieur le
ministre du gouvernement 7 vous
quinzaine d'amendements très important
qui a pour objet de mettre en oeuvre
l'engagement pris lors du conseil
européen des 19 et 20 mars 2009
consistant à augmenter les ressources du
fmi pour aider les pays confrontés à la
crise l'amendement proposé vise à mettre
en oeuvre l'engagement international de
la france s'agit concrètement modifier
l'article 2 de la loi du 26 décembre 45
rôle actif du fmi qui régit les
relations financières entre la france et
le fmi le fmi pourra après l'adoption de
la loi appelée auprès de la france les
sommes correspondantes et ainsi accordé
un soutien financier au pays
le sollicitant et monsieur le rapporteur
bien pas d'explication de vac qui est
pour et qui est contre il est adopté
nous l'article 7 été supprimés nous
baissons après d'article c'est un
amendement numéro 15 présenté par le
gouvernement
v la parole c'est le dernier à maman
monsieur le président il s'agit
simplement détendre et d'adapter aux
collectivités d'outre-mer les
dispositions de la présente proposition
de loi
pas d'opposition il est adopté je vais
être pas d'explications de vote sur son
ensemble j'entends bien la
d'explications de vote sur l'ensemble je
vais mettre voir l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi il n'y a pas
d'explications de vote qui est pour
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi s'il
vous plaît veuillez vous manifester qui
est contre abstention aux socialistes
la proposition de loi est adopté c'était
l'examen de la proposition de loi visant
à favoriser l'accès au crédit des pme
pour revoir cette séance votre site
internet publicsenat.fr
tout de suite le journal de 18 heures
présenté par sonia mabrouk et michel
conscient merci de votre fidélité et à
très bientôt sur public sénat